[Music]
the boys dying over there in Vietnam
something I got stolen there's something
undeniably special about mafia 3 the New
Orleans inspired setting in vintage 60
soundtrack combined with the incredibly
rich narrative to create a sense of
immersion not often found in triple-a
games at one point I was shooting my way
out of a swampy section of the Bayou to
the tune of Del Shannon's runaway and
just thought this is the coolest scene
ever but that feeling unfortunately
never extended to the rest of the game
the Mafia three's campaign contains
quite a few memorable moments like that
Bayou shootout they're buried under a
pile of repetitive filler missions and
underserved by david gameplay which adds
little to the standard sandbox shooter
formula we've seen in dozens of other
games and we're still the game suffers
technical blemishes from start to finish
the story follows Lincoln clay a man who
is many things an orphan adopted by the
leader of new Bordeaux's black mom a war
hero who returns home from Vietnam in
1968 and the victim of a vicious
betrayal at the hands of the city's
crime boss Sal marcano will [ __ ] son I'd
be lying if I didn't say I wasn't just a
little disappointed the ensuing plot
follows all the expected beats of a
revenge tale but it culminates in a
positively Shakespearean ending made all
the more impactful by our deep
understanding of each and every
character the story mixes cut scenes set
in 1968 with documentary footage shot in
the present day and video of a
congressional hearing that occurs
somewhere in-between it's a brilliant
way to tell a complete well-rounded
story even side characters receive
enough attention to feel
three-dimensional and tiny details like
store signage and radio hosts expert
capture the tumultuous time in place
that serves as the backdrop you'll even
find a few nods to longtime mafia fans
mafia two protagonist Vito Scaletta for
example returns as one of three under
bosses who allies with Lincoln against
poor tano Lincoln's quest for revenge
coincides with his rise to power power
he shares during a series of playable
sit-downs scenes in which Lincoln
gathers his Capo's around a table to
talk business basically every time you
capture new district you must assign
that district a leader who will grant
you new weapons and abilities in
exchange but ignore one of your partners
too many times and they might just turn
on you it's a clever way to embrace the
Mafia concept and a welcome through T G
contrast to the rest of the gun driven
gameplay unfortunately the systems work
better in concept than in practice in
part because the perks aren't
particularly well balanced Vito and
Cassandra offer plenty of desirable
perks like a time saving money
collection service and improved ammo
capacity for all weapons Burke on the
other hand can temporarily call off the
cops but oddly enough I never found the
cops to be much of a problem neglecting
work became a foregone conclusion after
the first couple meetings asking me the
lock day and half the district is a nice
gesture and all especially considering
you haven't given me [ __ ] since we off
the butcher but we all know the real
money isn't running the entire district
well the sit downs aren't a resounding
success they are at least a compelling
original idea the rest of mafia threes
gameplay however feels entirely
unoriginal the action consists primarily
of bare-bones driving and third-person
cover based shooting both of which we've
seen executed better in many other games
the gameplay is functional and even
enjoyable at times mostly thanks to the
hitman light stealth mechanics
cinematics cryptic takedowns and
gruesome yet satisfying enemy death
animations
Patamon boys but mafia 3 does nothing to
distinguish its generic moment-to-moment
gameplay from that of other sandbox
shooters and if score mechanics can't
even nail the basics at least not
completely swapping cover feels awkward
enemy AI is dumb as rocks weapons lack
variety none of this breaks the
experience but it does land the overall
quality somewhere between fine and
lackluster these problems are compounded
by the campaign's exhausting mission
structure after the game's excellent
opening portion a pattern quickly
emerges shakedown informants kill
enforcers smash up contraband steal cash
stashes and eventually take down a boss
figure it's a pattern that makes sense
in the context of the world and those
boss showdowns provide many of the
game's most unique and memorable
gameplay scenarios
problem is that pattern repeats over and
over again for the entire campaign and
the filler missions leading up to the
bigger faceoffs will never change as a
result much of the game feels
frustratingly repetitive and while the
city of new bordeaux is immense alive
and incredibly detailed there's not much
to do beyond the story missions there's
also no fast travel system you'll so I
spent in infuriating amount of time just
commuting to and from objectives these
issues are somewhat forgivable in light
of the exceptional storytelling which
kept me invested throughout but it's
impossible to overlook mafia threes
technical issues I experienced
everything from broken mission
objectives to enemies spotting me
through walls to a solid handful of hard
crashes and that's all in addition to
the fact that the game simply doesn't
look that great with blurry textures odd
lighting and object popping throughout
the game
[Music]
every aspect of mafia 3 is writing from
the dialogue to the mission descriptions
is excellently the obvious care and
craftsmanship that went into the
narrative elements should serve as a
model for all other Triple A games the
gameplay however just can't live up and
repetitive missions and technical
problems drive the experience down
further turning a game that could have
been truly great into one that has to
settle for good boys I clink it onesie
in a pan a always looking for home
always looking for a place to belong
Mackey Dottie Planet nom
[Music]
once that's lost you'd never get it back
you